Greetings and welcome to earthlink
cinema.
I am your host.
Garrick's were ameloid.
This week's artifact is jaws directed by
the wonder kid himself.
Stephen wonder.
The film follows police officer John
Brody.
The town's only lifeguard when a shark
rocks a girl back and forth until she
dies.
He tries to close down the beach so it
can't get to land,
but the mayor's deepen the pocket of
sustainable local business that crook,
the mayor's plan works for five minutes
until the shark eats chucky.
Naturally,
the town decides the safest solution is
for everyone to just try and kill it
themselves,
but not quint,
an actual shark hunter with a resume
longer than his nails.
Brody brings on a brilliant scientist
named hooper who offers his professional
opinion.
It was a shark.
The next day the fishermen catch dinner
and the mayor opens the beach,
but who bird calls bullshit.
Since this sharks belly has an airtight
alibi and said,
you still got a hell of a fish out there
on England day,
some kids pull a hilarious prank while
the shark pulls one of his own.
Oh wait.
And with no options left.
The capitalist mayor is forced to hire
quince and turn the town Communist.
What follows is a human male getaway on
a boat for the weekend full of fishing,
drinking,
and terrifying monologues about
subtraction.
So 1100 men when they were 16 and come
out of the sharks took the rest.
It's so fun.
Even the shark can't stay away.
And the trio try throwing barrels at it
like it's Mario,
even though its name is Dennis.
They hook the shark,
but their boat conveniently breaks down
just like me.
Anytime I watched the fault in our
quarks,
hooper tries to put it in a cage,
but ends up getting in himself the goof
while Quinn tries kicking it,
remembering he's a policeman.
Brody shoots Dennis until he explodes.
Jaws Herald and the age of Hollywood
blockbusters,
which always got there do come award
season.
It's got everything a human with eyes
could want from its merchandise tie-ins
to it's complex to notes score to its
high concept.
Premise high because you have to be
stoned to think of this for reasons
unknown to our archeologists earthlings
met this film with immense amounts of
critical thoughts.
Uh,
first for the species through a Marxist
Lens.
Amities devastation can be viewed as
retribution for capitalism,
a disease that made humans rich.
Well,
a few of them early on.
The film shows how the economic
interests of amities business owners
trump the needs of the common people.
I had a point of view and I think it
speaks for many of the motel.
How do you feel?
Even though the common folk can't count
[inaudible]
the mayor refuses to band swimming.
It would hurt the town's bottom line.
While you've Brodie is similarly
preoccupied with this rich dude sick
house.
I know you got a lot of founders
downtown,
but I've got a couple of problems with
the house or was she could take care of
one.
I've got some cats parking in front of
the house.
I can
lifeguard and handyman.
Well doesn't this cop do,
but ignoring the pleas of the common
folk nearly ruins the town after Dennis,
his reign of terror claims various
humans,
boats,
horses and boat porches.
The mayor finally allows brody hooper
and quint to go kill the shark,
even though they could have done it on
their own at any time.
This echoes marks belief that capitalism
will ultimately be overthrown by the
unhappy masses on a beach.
This transition of power cures Amedee of
its capitalist hangover so it can get
back to drinking.
At the same time,
jaws can be viewed more broadly as a
metaphor for corrupt government,
also known as government.
Indeed,
the film offered American earthlings a
way to vent their frustration with
politicians in the wake of Watergate
gate and this interpretation the mayor
stands in for Nixon sharing his famous
distrust for law enforcement or the
fellas.
Let's be reasonable,
half his pension for covering up
incriminating evidence.
What else could have done that to that
girl?
Bulk of ballet?
Well,
I think possibly,
yes,
call me over the phone
and his nautical themed suits when he's
publicly disgraced.
The audience experiences well-deserved
relief just as the American people did
when Nixon resigned from office to live
on the moon.
If psychology is more your cup of herb
water,
jaws can be read as a Freudian
cautionary tale.
It's all psychological.
Freud posited,
there were three sections to the human
brain.
The ID in charge of animal desires,
the Super Ego,
which controls morality and the Eggo,
which balances a healthy breakfast.
Dennis represents the primal desires of
the ID,
driven to consume things both
figuratively and literally.
The town and it's government or the
Superego,
imposing laws ostensibly for the greater
good.
And the Eggo is where these two forces
meet,
usually the shore.
But here,
the balance has broken down rather than
finding the line between mindless
consumption and moral snobbery,
the aid runs wild baby.
It's only when brody kills the shark
that harmony corrine is restored,
symbolized by him standing in a boat,
half submerged in water,
where he'll eventually drown.
But the prevailing interpretation comes
from filmmaker Stephen wonder who
astutely proclaimed.
It's a movie about a shark named Dennis
for earthlink cinema.
I'm Derek's warm,
and if you haven't heard,
I've started my own channel to see all
future episodes and subscribe.
Click here.
[inaudible].